-Thank you so much.
Enjoy yourself.
Thank you for being here.
Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
You're here. You made it.
Thank you for watching.
Well, guys, I saw that today is
National Singles Awareness Day.
-Thank God.
[ Cheers ]
-Yeah, I could be wrong, but I'm
pretty sure that the day
when people are most aware
they're single
is Valentine's Day,
but I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
Actually, I think Singles
Awareness Day should be on
Thanksgiving 'cause that's when
your family makes you
the most aware you're single.
[ Laughter ]
"When are you going to date
somebody?
"I want grandkids."
That's right.
It's Singles Awareness Day.
And in a cruel twist of fate,
it falls on hump day.
[ Laughter ]
Actually, single people are
like, "It's not that we don't
want to date someone, it's just
that we really enjoy
canceling plans."
I mean, that's fun.
That's right.
It is Singles Awareness Day,
and this is nice -- stores
actually sold candy for it.
I think they might've just
reused some of
the candy from Valentine's Day.
Take a look. First there's...
And you go, "Well, that's --"
Then there's...
And you go, "Wait, that's --"
Next there's...
-Wow.
-That's more of a public
service.
-For Smokey the Bear.
-And finally, of course,
there's the classic...
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Not gonna happen."
Hey, in honor of Singles
Awareness Day, I just want to
take a moment to acknowledge all
the single people out there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Don't worry if you haven't found
someone yet.
Some people were single
throughout their 20s,
30s, and 40s.
And after a while...
[ Laughter ]
...those people start to wonder
if "it" would ever happen.
And they practice kissing on
their pillows.
They even...
[ Laughter ]
They even post to Craigslist
seeking someone who likes to
"get freaky-deaky with a scalp
that's squeaky."
[ Laughter ]
But in the end --
But in the end,
even that guy found love.
So keep the faith.
Worst case, you could just
accept a life of celibacy.
Hang in there, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey, James.
That's what you get for not
coming to rehearsal.
[ Laughter ]
Guys, get this.
I heard that last night,
President Biden celebrated
Valentine's Day by ordering
takeout from a French restaurant
in D.C.
What? He has Air Force One.
He literally could have flown
Jill to France.
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, Biden eats dinner at
3:00 p.m.
How hard is it to get a table?
[ Laughter ]
Yep, Biden ordered takeout,
which was kind of fun because
it's not often you see
an Uber Eats guy
with a Secret Service motorcade.
[ Laughter ]
"I accidentally went to
Pennsylvania Street.
I didn't know 1200 Pennsylvania
Street was the place, but..."
[ Laughter ]
The delivery guy called him
like, "Sorry --"
Oh, sorry, that was the joke
I just did.
Oops.
[ Laughter ]
Should have came --
-Whoa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I should have came to
rehearsal.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, Valentine's Day was
yesterday.
Personally, I had a great time.
Nancy and I got dinner at one of
our favorite spots.
Tariq, what did you do?
-Oh, my wife and I got
a babysitter so we could just
chill at home,
just the two of us.
You know, catch up on our shows
and order takeout.
-That's sweet. Higgins, how was
your Valentine's Day?
-Not great.
I got catfished.
-Sorry.
Wait, aren't you married?
-Yeah, I got catfished by
my wife.
[ Laughter ]
-How is that possible?
-Well, I never met her in
person. We would just FaceTime.
But last night, I was like,
"Hey, we've been married
like 30 years.
Maybe we should meet."
But then she blocked me
on Facebook.
[ Laughter ]
-But you have kids with her.
-Turns out my kids were
catfishing me too.
[ Laughter ]
-What?
-Yeah.
They were actors hired to play
my children.
I guess most of them used to
work on "iCarly."
[ Laughter ]
-Why is this happening to you?
-I guess that Roku is doing
a new prank show called
"Steve Higgins' Whole Life
Is a Lie."
It's like "The Truman Show"
but not heartwarming at all.
You know what the worst thing
is, Jimmy?
-I haven't heard the worst thing
so far?
-No.
I'm not even the announcer for
"The Tonight Show."
[ Laughter ]
-You're not?
-No.
I'm a hologram.
Real me is a 16-year-old kid
strapped into
a V.R. headset in Montana.
I gotta go, Jimmy.
My mom's calling me for dinner.
-What's going on?
-Okay, Mom.
I'll be right there. God.
[ Applause ]
-Steve Higgins.
I love that character.
That is a great guy.
Wow, amazing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That cost us $4 million to do.
-Are you serious?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I missed rehearsal.
-I'll fill you in.
Some political news.
Today, Nikki Haley officially
kicked off her presidential
campaign.
And during her speech, she
called for politicians
older than 75 to have
a mandatory competency test.
Yep, competency tests for
politicians over 75.
Then Biden said,
"I have a better idea.
Competency tests for politicians
over 75."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, she said older politicians
need mental checks
and new ideas.
Then Trump looked at Biden like,
"Wow, she's really going
after you."
[ Laughter ]
Some more political news,
Senator Bernie Sanders said that
public school teachers should
get a minimum salary
of $60,000 a year.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Then every other senator was
like, "Teacher's pet."
[ Laughter ]
Well, some movie news here,
guys.
This weekend, "Ant-Man and the
Wasp: Quantumania" is hitting
theaters,
and I am excited about this.
Paul Rudd is fantastic
in everything.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Ant-Man."
Tariq, this weekend, you gonna
see "Ant-Man"?
-Can't, man.
-Why not?
-Hanging with my aunt, man.
-Doing what?
-Buying a plant, man.
-You're buying a plant
for your aunt
instead of seeing "Ant-Man"?
-No, no.
I'm buying a plant with my aunt
to give to Kevin Durant, man.
-Why would Kevin Durant want
a plant from your aunt, man?
-Because Kevin Durant needs
a plant from my "ahnt" --
I mean my aunt, to give to
Steven Van Zandt, man.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Rim shot ]
The whole bit.
The whole bit is "ant."
[ Laughter ]
You're gonna see "Ahnt-Man"?
Gonna see "Ahnt-Man"?
-I meant to come to rehearsal,
but I said, "I can't, man."
[ Laughter ]
[ Rim shot ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's good.
-It's not gonna get better
than that.
-I don't know. We should just go
to the end, right?
I don't think we're gonna find
this --
So, guys, some more business
news --
[ Laughter ]
Some business news, Chipotle is
launching a spin-off restaurant
called Farmesa Fresh Eatery.
Damn, in 2023,
even our restaurants are getting
spin-offs.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, both Chipotle and E. coli
were like, "We're expanding."
[ Laughter ]
Well, listen to this.
Cybersecurity experts are
warning that electric vehicles
could be
the next prime targets
for hackers.
-Ooh.
-Which explains why my car keeps
getting e-mails about
"hot sedans in your area."
[ Laughter and applause ]
And finally, it is Wednesday.
It is time for "WeTweet."
Here we go.
-♪ WeTweet ♪
♪ WeTweet ♪
-Welcome to "WeTweet."
This is where we, as a group,
decide something that we should
post on Twitter.
I'm going to show you five
different tweets and we're all
going to vote on whether you
like each one or not.
You all have voting clickers
at your seats?
Yep.
You can vote for all of them.
You can vote for none of them.
Whatever you want.
And we're gonna see the results
live.
Higgins, Roots, you guys have
clickers too?
-Got it.
-Whatever tweet gets the most
likes, we will tweet it out live
on the show so that you can all
like it and "wetweet" it.
-Whoo!
-It's a shared experience.
Alright, you guys ready?
Everyone have your clickers?
Hands up. Hands up if you got
the clickers.
Alright, perfect. Alright, good.
Alright, first tweet. It says...
[ Light laughter ]
Mm.
-Wow, silence.
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
-Maybe they're laughing
on the inside.
-On the inside of their thigh?
-Yeah.
Don't talk about the inside of
anyone's thigh.
-What's that?
It's Valentine's Day.
-I don't even know if I have to
check the votes on this one,
but let's just do it for fun.
Let's see the results.
-Ooh!
[ Sad tuba ]
-Wow.
-64.
-No one got stabbed by a pencil
in grade school?
[ Laughter ]
-Okay. Four people did, yeah.
So it work --
the math works out.
It's correct. Everyone's --
Everyone's clickers work.
Alright. This next one says...
[ Laughter ]
Well, now I feel like the Roots
are playing the music
lighter and lighter.
Yeah, I mean, that sells
the bit, you know?
Alright, that's not gonna work
either.
Alright, let's see the results
on this one.
It's probably worse than
the first one.
Oh! Hey, alright, not bad.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you. Not bad.
-It hit triple digits.
-Yeah. They don't necessarily
get better.
-No.
-I will say that.
[ Laughter ]
This next one here says...
It is getting that way.
-Yeah.
-It is getting that way where
I'm like...
It is getting that way. Alright.
You all voted?
Let's see the results.
Alright. Not bad.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Next up, it says...
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
-That's pretty good actually.
I like that idea.
That's not bad.
Cast your votes here.
Alright. Let's see the results
on this one.
[ Drumroll ]
Yeah!
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's gonna be the hit.
That's gonna be the winner.
-That took the lead.
-I'll do the last one just
for fun, but that one's gonna be
the winner.
This last one is...
[ Laughter ]
Cast your votes.
Alright, let's see the results.
-I don't know.
That one might win.
-You like that one?
-I like that one.
-No, I think it's the one
before that.
Everyone's laughing at that one.
I don't know.
Alright, here we go.
Let's see the results.
-Oh!
-Oh, that's right.
The winner is number four.
[ Dinging ]
I will post this during
the commercial break.
If you see it on your feed,
give it a like,
give it a "wetweet" and enjoy.